would you believe it if I said I missed
you no I need your help
Matthew youth any best Mike you dressed
well sweetheart you don't break into my
house and then talk to me about trust
what do you want from me you fight
better than anyone I know and I have
information the Yakuza never left
that's impossible I drove them out of
New York City no you didn't there just
hibernated and what should take out all
of their enemies
now New York is right for the taking if
we do this nobody dies do you understand
hungry every time I walk up those stairs
I wonder today's the day you're dead in
your living room there are horrible
things happening in this city I'm done
apologizing to you for who I am
the city needs me
this isn't your city anymore
my way isn't working what a fender
- well has begun with you there's
nothing we can take fight there I'm cold
the hand you cannot stop what we have
started the rising is coming
you've been working out by the way I
appreciate that sign it's hot in D to F
no longer this one shoe it against I
quite forgot